[Colt] I'm going crazy.
Abby, she left me.
Don't want to see my dad.
I partnered up
with my cousin.
Couple weeks ago, he run off
with Rooster's ex
and all the money.
God.
Your life blows.
Yup.
[Lisa] You know
I like you, Colt.
But the fact is,
we're competitors.
So if you do go under,
it'll be good for me.
[Colt] I just want you
to know that
I'm a good father, husband.
I got one of them
stick figure family decals.
Stick figure daddy Colt
is giving stick figure
mommy Abby space,
just like she asked for.
That kid can't catch a break.
Come on,
it's the middle of the night.
[Heather] Are you drunk?
-No.
-Oh, my...
Yeah.
[Colt] How am I
supposed to survive?
What if I was
your ranch hand?
Ain't no way
you're taking orders from me.
Hell, you can't even follow
the directions
on the back of a TV dinner.
You wanna stick around,
watch some football?
I would, but I already have
a school thing.
[making alarm sound]
[laughs]
Nerd alert, right, Dad?
Whoop, whoop!
Shut the... [beep] ...up.
[vocalizing]
♪ Gotta get up♪
♪ Away from here♪
Morning, boys.
-Beautiful day.
-Is this a trap?
If I say yes, you gonna
call me a... [beep] ...idiot?
No, I'm in a good mood.
Huh? Tell your face.